DRO those thought out there all thought
out for sure yeah they're all thought
out they need working on now there's
freezing outside it's a good to clear
the freezer of all the caribou we've got
how we put some more fish in they're
gonna have to leave the door open
because if you don't have a breeze this
will turn moldy and if we leave the door
open and close the front door and this
will freeze really well I'm pretty sure
and no dogs will get to it
good Ted lots of meat there oh yeah this
will get us by until it freezes solid
outside anyway think we got plenty we
got plenty from this summer to these
bulls we got earlier in the month here
and I do us plenty fine at plenty of
caribou if we hadn't spent the whole
summer gathering food and earlier this
month catching these caribou here then
we'd be screwed you have enough meat no
and Jon's making some dinner so dinner
is just about done let's go check it out
now we're done with the meats
good cheese some caribou ass and some
rice if it's quite eat it up yet
sorry just cut it up like six
that should be good enough for everybody
thank you for cooking while we butchered
yeah good teamwork this is like a
pigskin but it's not just caribou fat
Chris crispy scared with that
you